what or who are men defending women from
and the answer of course is other men
[Music]
should we abandon the idea that women
should be defended by men Marianne would
you lead us off sure well I'd like to
start from the premise that in all but
one respect women are absolutely equal
to men
women are just as intelligent as men if
you look at the IQ distribution women's
and men's IQs are identical except at
the very far ends of the bell curve
and if you look at academic achievement
actually girls and young women
outperform boys and young men at every
stage of the educational process from
kindergarten right through to PhD so
intellectually we are absolutely men's
equals
were just as competent as men in fact
lots of studies show that women are more
competent than men in certain regards
houses sold by women tend to raise more
by female estate agents tend to go for
higher prices and those sold by male
estate agents female sergeants are
slightly more successful at saving lives
than male surgeons so in lots of
respects women are certainly is good and
in some sense is better they also
actually make marginally better leaders
than men so one interesting academic
study asked subordinates to rate their
bosses and people who worked for female
bosses rated them much higher than
people who worked for male bosses though
the male bosses rated themselves more
highly than the female bosses
and in studies
of types of leadership transformational
leadership is seen to be the most
successful transformational leadership
is leadership in which you engage your
employees you are more democratic less
sort of top-down and hierarchical you
inspire them you listen to them and
women on the whole meta studies show
make better transformational leaders
than men
but I did say in one all but one respect
and that respect is physical size and
strength and we're never going to change
the fact that on average men are just
bigger and stronger than women
men can rape women men can kill women
men can beat up women in any
hand-to-hand combat is very likely that
the man will win and I know personally I
feel much safer walking home from the
tube with my husband at night than I do
walking on my own and I'm very happy for
him to defend me in those circumstances
I just you know feel much more protected
and much more safe where my husband is
there with me as I would probably with
almost any man I feel much less
vulnerable to attack and we're never
going to be able to change that
but beyond that I want to recast the
notion of men defending women from a
sort of rather old-fashioned chivalric
patriarchal notion to a much more modern
one
men as allies of women
now in the book I've recently written
The Authority Gap I talk about all sorts
of behavior that happens routinely to
women however senior they are in work
contexts and also in Social context
which is women being underestimated
being patronized being interrupted and
talked over having their ideas ignored
in favor of men's having their expertise
challenged and having their Authority
resisted and this is a sort of behavior
that I would really like to change it's
only going to happen if men change their
behavior and Men start acting as allies
to women and in that sense I would love
men to defend us and Beyond just the
authority Gap behavior when it comes to
the gender pay Gap and much worse thing
such as sexual harassment violence
against women
um you know calling names uh sort of
sexist behavior on the street public
offenses I would like other men to say
to men who display this sort of sex
system misogynist Behavior this is no
longer acceptable in other words to
defend us against continuing sexism in
society
and my view is that if you it's very
similar to racism so if you look back 10
or 20 years it was quite common though
horrible in a group of white people for
a white person to make a casually racist
joke that is no longer common because
the other white people will say oh I'm
you know I'm not putting up with that
that is no longer acceptable you can't
do that anymore
and so I would like in groups of men if
they see any sort of sexist or
misogynist behavior taking place that
they call it out and that's a sort of
Defense
that I would like to see from men for me
as a woman that they start saying to
other men this is as unacceptable as
racism and then the old-fashioned sexist
dinosaurs will feel just as marginalized
as racists do today
thanks very much indeed Marianne a very
clear exposition of that opening
position could we turn to you you know
and this question of should we abandon
the idea that women should be defeated a
certain defeated
undefeated
defended defended by men
of course Hasty recovery
uh women should defeat men maybe
um
should women be defended by men so two
things that I want to say about that the
first is I think the question is very
revealing of how we think about
um men defending women especially in
terms of War
um so embedded into the question is the
idea that men actually go to war in
order to defend women and the follow-up
question from that is
what or who are men defending women from
and the answer of course is other men
and if that is true that men are
defending women from other men then it
is also true that women live in
patriarchal societies
um which of course then means that yes
on some level women do need to be
um defended from the Societies in which
we live but the question I think is also
and importantly especially telling of
how we continue to erase women from
history because women are not actually
defended by men even in war situations
so women suffer disproportionately from
war
um
Wars exacerbate inequality both during
the war and after the war they increase
rape obviously sex trafficking domestic
violence so what exactly is it that
women are being defended from at the end
of the day and secondly the Erasure of
women from history and from our current
narratives happens
um when we frame the question in this
way because women actually defend
themselves
um women have always done that women
have always fought in Wars so even in in
Ukraine today about I don't think
there's an accurate estimate yet because
the war is still ongoing but about 30
000 of the soldiers in Ukraine were
women
um these are tens of thousands of people
who are in combat
um so who these women are defending
their country you know they're not it's
not men who are defending women
um I Googled
the word soldier in preparation for this
discussion and I had to scroll through
countless Pages before a single image of
a female Soldier came up
um so you know we're completely erasing
the fact that women are in combat and
have been for very long
um
King Charles the first he actually had
to create a law
that said that women were not allowed to
dress as men because so many women were
dressing as men in order to go into into
combat
um in the UK it's not until
2015 that David Cameron during David
Cameron's role that women were allowed
to enter combative roles in the UK Army
so women have been banned from defending
themselves but that doesn't mean that
they they haven't done so
um so ultimately and and I also want to
add you know of course uh you know women
have not only defended themselves in
combat in armies if you look at black
women's history you have slave revolts
that took place throughout the the
centuries these are ways of women
engaging in in fighting so yeah uh men
don't defend women
um they defend the idea of the male hero
who defends women
you know
Mina thanks very much indeed and let me
turn now to address this question of
should we abandon the idea that women
should be defended by men to my
oppenheim Maya hello everyone so yeah
should we abandon the idea that women
should be defended by men I mean yeah I
find that a paternalistic condescending
view to take you know it costs women as
de facto children as second-class
Citizens but saying that you know if
another human being sees another human
being you know being attacked or in any
way harm I do think they should stand up
for them but I'm going to look at this
question in relation to war because that
seems to be you know the main Crux of
the debate so the notion that men you
know the majority of people that make up
military positions are men you know it
is women that are more likely to stay
home in situations of conflict the
notion that that is the case because men
are out defending women yeah I don't
agree with that that feels very
erroneous I would say is because you've
got dependence in society that we've got
children you know babies and children
who without someone to look after them
will die the best person to stay home to
look after them the person that you know
is gonna
their presence will result in the child
having you know least trauma will be the
parent often the mother is closer to the
child so it makes sense for the mother
to stay home we still live in a society
where the burden of unpaid labor Falls
heavily on women women are far more
likely to take on the Lion's Share of
child care to look after elderly sick
relatives I think that you know I'm
against forcing conscription on women
given we live in a grossly unequal
Society it will just deepen an entrench
already existing equal inequality you
know women are subjected to grave human
rights abuses around the world women
already disproportionately suffer during
war there are so many you know facts I
can tell you to back this up but yeah I
think that you know as you've said
Global gender-based violence increases
also women and girls are overrepresented
in populations that are displaced by War
women often you know women are
physically more vulnerable in the sense
that you know women get pregnant women
are reliant on contraception abortions
these things do not stop in a conflict
Zone also the fact that you know 70 of
um of those that die in Modern War are
civilians many of these are women and
children so yeah my conclusion would be
if we lived in a gender equal Society
well I think there would be less Wars
but if we did live in a gender equal
Society I would believe in conscription
for men and for women but given we don't
then conscription for both will just
deepen pre-existing inequalities
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below or visit iai.tv for
more debates and talks from the world's
leading thinkers on today's biggest
ideas